good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday hope everybody's
having a gorgeous day it's a Taylor
Tuesday because Taylor schrecker's in
studio with me hey girlfriend I love it
let's let's coin it Taylor Tuesday
Taylor Tuesday we could also do wacky
whack job Wednesday well I think that
that's more my energy we could do
Thirsty Thursdays which I'm the most
thirsty we could do feral Fridays I
could go on actually you're the Pharaoh
one men hating Mondays girl you know
what I was much more of a man-hater when
I was a straight woman now I am a man
sympathizer oh the struggle is real for
us straight men that's so you are they
basically a straight man straight man
it's I'm I'm worried for them you look
beautiful thank you for showing up today
and showing up in a gorgeous outfit it's
kind of like a sign of respect when you
some people come in here mostly me
looking like a you know a slob you
really don't not anymore not when I have
guests on because I used to like just
dress it's a podcast I used to wear
merch and leggings and like Shannon Ford
and Paige to Sorbo would forget in here
forgot I'd be like they'd literally be
wearing heels and I'm like oh man I'm
actually wearing like the thing I wore
to sleep last night I'm wearing heels so
you look gorgeous but I am because I'm
virgin tunnel first of all I want to
tell everybody tell them tell them Not
only was she on time she was early today
it's early we're getting started yeah
early yeah I learned a lesson thank you
um verbal abuse works very well I mean
uh that's something I've come to learn
in my old age yeah I like it actually I
know you do
quit me and then uh but I commuted here
so I have a change of shoes I'm a real
New Yorker like a like a true poor
person no
like a native New Yorker you know uh
what was the show not billions
um uh hello session thank you made me
feel so ashamed oh when they were
dogging the big purse are you wearing a
Lotus ludicrously capacious bag what
does she have a change of shoes in there
for the subway she does that was
honestly like one of the best lines ever
written in succession
really it felt like a personal attack so
tell me what's new with you Taylor's
tracker I mean it has been literally
less than a week since you've been here
but so much goes on so much has changed
I mean I'm wearing denim on denim now
it's giving Canadian tuxedo thank you um
my wife actually insisted I wear this I
am denim shirt denim pants Denim heels
[__] fabulous thank you do you like
this for her I do said hey like made me
wear her bracelets and she tried to have
me wear the necklaces you know that she
always wears and I was like it's okay
it's too much it's too much and you're
giving titty like it needs you have a
tan so you don't want to thank you I
also don't want to be like her like
weird little lesbian doll wow those are
fighting words
so we had to stop with the necklaces but
yeah great thank you girl you look great
we look great we really do look great
let's do another weekly ozone big update
um I wanted to get your take on
something because you can speak to this
please so yesterday Jack and I were
talking about the upcoming Jewish
holiday before I saw and Jackie called
me a cheater because I'm gonna be on
ozempic cheater cheater pumpkin eater
yeah yeah okay but let's just
it's important to know that Yom Kippur
falls on a Monday and I take my weekly
shots on Wednesdays so okay okay so like
today is Tuesday I haven't taken my shot
yet me too I take mine tomorrow last
night I was eating like a crazy person
I'm starving so you really do get your
full on appetite back which also you
don't know how to control anymore so you
are kind of like next level but I will
say
it is definitely easier for something
like that I mean it's it's cheating it's
100 cheating I don't think that is
cheating it's Assisted Living it's an
assistance for sure it's a tool it's a
tool exactly but I was on ozembic last
Yom Kippur and I don't remember but if I
don't remember it must have been fine
well I remember last year you were
complaining about your phone more than
anything over food yeah yeah you
realized how addicted you were I it's a
really big problem like how are you with
your phone because you know how awful I
am okay but you're let me ask you a
question you're so bad with your phone
like you never respond if you text me
I'm responding within 10 seconds when
you wake up in the morning what's the
first thing you do I grab my phone okay
because my alarm goes off oh right I
actually go on Instagram way more than I
should and I know I'm like actively I
hate it yeah and I'm like and I'm not
like on anything good I'm on like the
weirdest algorithm of like
um like how to get a mortgage and when
the best time like I don't know how I
fell into this hole but if your phone's
trying to tell you something it's time
to buy a house it is what seriously Tay
and I went out to see my sister-in-law
and brother-in-law to go watch the
Eagles and I was like I really don't
want to move to The Burbs wow and I was
like I don't want to have to make new
friends like I love my friends yeah I
don't want to make new friends I know
and then Tate was like what about when
all of our friends move to The Burbs
well then we all just need to move
together that's what I said I said
Claudia would never do that without
infection I would let you know if I was
thinking about moving and I would give
you the opportunity to buy the house
next door
um really do you think you'll ever move
to The Burbs and if you move out of the
city where do you think y'all go I don't
know people ask me this question a lot
mostly because Olivia and Jackie moved
yeah I think everybody's just kind of
waiting for me to move to Florida and
it's really not on my list of things to
do it's a really nice life but it's just
not for me you promise I promise but I
don't know I could you know one day have
a kid I think when you have a kid like
everything changes they ruin everything
so maybe I'll just be like so inclined
to be near my sisters and their kids I
don't know I don't know I could see
myself moving out of the city I could
also see myself never moving out of the
city I really don't know but where would
you move I don't know this is the thing
and also I just think we're like
I can't even think about living in a
house right now like getting a mortgage
seven percent it's like that [__] like
no I can't I need the right to go back
down I gotta wait for the market to
shift I don't even know what I'm talking
about but I just know I'm not paying
seven percent do you feel like I've been
thinking about this yeah that like the
pressure to purchase a home is like
actually valid and it's a good
investment and like it keeps going up
like I've been watching oh did you watch
selling OC I did it okay but that's a
very good question but like when I watch
it like the OC like a [__] [__] turd
house yeah on the smallest part of land
goes for 2.5 million yeah so now I'm
getting scared like wait but like are
they inflating the prices but like right
no it's it's a lot of things like that's
a good question like if you buy a house
like is it a guaranteed good investment
I don't [__] know and like what if
it's not and I just said like and my
whole life savings on a house and people
that get houses like I have friends that
are recent homeowners and they're like
this is a [__] racket oh the money
Olivia's husband oh my God hates being a
homeowner he's like it's just an endless
Pro problems endless money endless
issues you need people coming technician
electrician he said it's endless he
hates it that's my point so many people
hate it and I want to say I absolutely
love being a renter it's such a peaceful
life except when you're scared that you
are gonna have to move well that and it
used to be that you could really rent
above like you could rent an apartment
you would really never be able to afford
to buy us but now with the market in New
York I'm only talking about New York
fair you everyone wants to rent because
I think after covet it's like so
uncertain like is New York coming back
like it's just safer to rent like yeah
and I think you're really not able to
now you're renting so much money for
something like kind of crappy totally so
I don't know I'm not a real estate
expert I'm not Ryan Sirhan if we were
smart we'd legit pull our money together
and start like a commune of sorts if we
were smart we would have bought houses
during covet
when the interest rates were so low God
I don't know how anybody like made a
life-altering decision during covet like
the world stopped I mean I made a
decision to gain 45 pounds oh I mean I
made a decision to like Vape again yeah
disgusting slob drink more than I've
ever drank yeah eat more than I've ever
eaten like sleep until like 1pm sleep
like make my house slobber's Paradise
yeah I made a lot of decisions during
covet not one of them were good not one
benefited me in any way shape or form
not a singular good decision was made I
interrupted you do you have a question
about ozamic oh it was about Yom Kippur
yes and do you think I'm cheating 100 I
mean with Yom Kippur specifically I mean
listen okay so are you and I as ozempi
Queens technically cutting the line I
don't like the word cheating right
because people are they they've been
calling it um we're line Cutters no
what's what do they what do they call it
um because it bothers me when people say
taking the easy way out taking the easy
way out well I implore the people who
have criticisms of what we're doing you
know what you should do stop taking your
car walk everywhere you know what you
should do you should email find a pigeon
attach a [__] letter and send it to
your grandma like these are called
modern day advancements no everything we
do is a shortcut listen Taylor I love
you and I want to support this analogy I
don't like really like understand the
car thing
because it's a modern right it's a it's
a faster way of getting somewhere yes
and this is a faster way of losing
weight in a more efficient way it's
actually it's not faster fine it's more
efficient more efficient and so it's not
driving is efficient more efficient yeah
yeah but you know what you want to go
see your friends over in Europe take a
boat how dare you fly it's too efficient
I really am not entertaining there's a
whole like travel analogy like
like like I I get it I guess yeah I know
I get it well it makes sense to me have
you ever um read Gary Genetti's book no
I know you're new today brand new Taylor
Ray Jenkins exclusive Jenkins read
but you should regard Genetti's book one
because it's just like funny short
stories they're really short and it's
like it's fabulous but um he tells a
story about like his uh one of his main
methods of travel when he was a young
kid was cruise ships because his dad
worked for a cruise ship and he would
just get free so when he did like a
semester in London all the kids like you
know flew and he took the QE2 home
that's what I'm saying it's the funniest
story you should really read the book
it's excellent but um have you ever been
on a cruise
um once I barfed everywhere never again
really I'm like so scared what kind of
cruise was it it was just like a day
cruise in Florida it was today yeah it
was thank God it was just a day and it's
considered a cruise I was talking about
like a big no no it was a big ass cruise
ship thousands of people yes I mean
listen I was traumatized so I might have
blocked how long I was there for you
only go for a day I I honestly don't
know why it was just today but I I'm
swearing to you it was a cruise ship and
the way I was so sick I get very seasick
I get seasick on a raft in my hot tub
well maybe you should stop floating in
there for hours on end but that is how
you got so 10 this summer here's how I
got so damn you're so tan I hate you
girl I'm so scared for when it goes away
no but you know what you worked really
hard at it I did I didn't even try to
get tan therefore I'm not yeah but like
it's going to eventually go away what
are your thoughts on like tanning like
you know Lauren Bostick is very you know
skin care forward get the [__] out of
the sun yes what are your thoughts on
that as a woman of a certain age you
know so what you look very good for your
age by the way thank you I think it's a
handful of things I think I started
getting Botox when I was 18 because of
the blinkies yeah so it was like so it
wasn't like a vanity thing it was like a
medical thing but when you're there
honey with a needle to your face do it
up get me in the forehead 100 so um I
think that that has a big part of it or
has to do with it
um it must be genetics my mom is so
young I said to my mom like Mom you look
so good like I'm fine and then she said
to me well you live a lot harder than I
do which is accurate you live a lot
harder that's a way of putting it the
drinking of course the smoking right the
other things right
but she's not wrong but I feel like now
that I'm at the age that I'm at I mean
Babette those jeans are kicking in no
you look very good for your for a 40
year old woman thank you like and I
always forget that you're older than me
I love when you say that do you feel
like it's because I have such a youthful
Spirit yes AKA because I'm so immature
no no you're not immature like you
really are just like fresh
thank you and like young I really always
forget that there's like an age gap
between us oh Claudia literally anything
like you you feel like 32 to me oh Queen
but you're not
but I'm not and either is Theo
get the [__] out of my studio [__] I'm
sorry I'll be right I came for you I
won't try it no I walked right into it I
walked I leaned into it you walked me
right into it I did I watched right into
it um we have Fast Five today they're
actually really good stories a lot of
strike news Okay um so without further
Ado if it's okay with you I would love
to dive in please here are the fast five
stories that yo need to know today's
episode is brought to you by Legacy box
what was your favorite childhood memory
caught on film or videotape do you have
an easy way to watch it or share it with
your friends and family or even post it
probably not but lucky for you we have
found a solution Legacy box our home
video tapes which were all VH vhs's are
some of our most prized memories and for
so many years they just sat in a box in
our basement like decaying and Legacy
box is not about that life like they are
here to make things easy for you the
process is so easy it is the simple and
safe solution for digitizing all your
family's precious memories and when you
go to legacybox.com toast you can enjoy
40 off when you get started with Legacy
box today super easy you send in your
legacy box fill it with your old VHS
tapes camcorder tapes pictures whatever
you got and their team will
professionally digitize everything by
hand in the USA you will get it back on
a cloud or the thumb drive as long along
with your Originals they've digitized
over 15 different types of analog media
so whether you've got those VHS tapes
like I have you know Queen of the 90s
singing Spice Girls in the backyard or
you have Super 8 millimeter film reels
photo negatives whatever it is they've
got you covered after 10 years in
business Legacy box is the world's
largest digitizer they've helped over a
million families relive wedding days
chaotic childhood Christmases and even
road trips to Yellowstone it's really
the best gift to give someone because
they just sit there and the longer they
sit in a basement or an attic whether
it's like super hot or super cold that
can actually affect and ruin and destroy
your tapes so take care of it go to
legacybox.com toast to save 40
um by today send in when you're ready
only when you go to legacybox.com toast
will you get get that 40 off just make
sure to buy it today you can send it in
whenever you're ready legacybox.com
post today's episode is also brought to
you by stamps.com the Holiday Rush means
more mailing and shipping for your
business but it doesn't have to mean
more stress stamps.com has been helping
businesses Like Yours save time and
money for 25 years and they can help you
get ready for the holiday ramp up all
you need is stamps.com premium rates for
all your postage needs so stamps.com is
your own personal post office wherever
you are with stamps.com all you need is
a computer and a printer they'll even
send you a free scale so you'll have
everything you need to get started now
taking care of orders or going is going
to go on even easier with the stamps.com
mobile app if you need a package pickup
you can easily schedule it through the
stamps.com dashboard and if you sell
products online stamps.com seamlessly
connects with every major Marketplace
and shopping cart if you're running low
on supplies you can order shipping and
mailing supplies labels even printers
from the supply store at stamps.com
you're getting huge carrier discounts up
to 84 off USPS and UPS rates to help
your bottom line plus stamps.com
automatically tells you the cheapest and
fastest shipping options available to
you it's been a postage partner for the
last 25 years they have been an
indispensable resource for over a
million businesses you're getting access
to the USPS and UPS services that you
need right from your computer anytime
day or night no lines no traffic no
waiting so get your business ready for
the holiday Rush get started with
stamps.com today sign up with promo code
toast for a special offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts required just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code toast
okay first up is Drew Barrymore like
last time we spoke about her she was a
victim yeah we're very very worried for
her today she's kind of the villain no
so the writer skills of America is
slamming Drew Barrymore for uh returning
to her talk show amid the strike ooh
four months after the wga officially
went on strike following failed
negotiations with the amptp and two
months after seg after joined them on
the picket line Drew Barrymore has
confirmed that her eponymous daytime
talk show will return first season four
on September 18th literally in a few
days yikes so in a statement shared to
social media on September 10th she like
explained a lot and said a whole bunch
of nothing so I don't know if you
remember a few months ago she was
supposed to host the MTV movie and TV
Awards yes and the strike hadn't
officially begun yet it was like about
to begin but in solidarity she took a
step back so she kind of positioned
herself as like an activist yeah for sag
a dangerous place to live wait nobody
asked her to do especially if she's
gonna kind of renege on that and now go
back to her talk show so she cited that
she said I'm I need a choice to walk
away from the MTV film and television
Awards because I was the host and it had
a direct conflict with what the strike
was dealing with which was Studio
streamers film and television it was
also in the first week of the strike and
so I did what I thought was the
appropriate thing at the time to stand
in solidarity with the writers hmm
you know is it like that she she was
there first and now she gets to like
fall out first no maybe she sounds like
she's like she it sounds like she's
saying this has gone on like a little
too long like I want to go back to work
this is the best of her statement
however I am making the choice to come
back for the first time in the strike
for our show that may have my name on it
but it is bigger than just me I own this
choice we are in compliance with not
discussing or promoting film and
television that is struck of any kind we
launched live in the global pandemic our
show was built on sensitive times and
has only functioned throughout what the
real world is going through in real time
I want to be there to provide what
writers I want to be there to provide
what writers do so well which is a way
of bringing us together or help us make
sense of The Human Experience I hope for
a resolve for everyone as soon as soon
as possible we've navigated difficult
times since we first came on air and so
I take a step forward to start season
four Once Again with an astute humility
big mistake big mistake I mean her first
of all No One's Gonna Be able to come on
and promote projects so celebrities are
not coming on she won't be able to
weirdly crawl into people's laps and
make them feel uncomfortable so that's
literally half the show right for sure
does have writers it is a wga show so
those people will not be returning right
so you have no writers and you have no
guests what the [__] are you doing what
are you doing maybe she needs the money
because of her stalker and she has to
pay for so much security the thing is
she's the type of person who I think
people perceive as the one percent in
this strike absolutely definitely has
like an image issue where people don't
understand they're like oh how I feel so
bad for Leonardo DiCaprio yeah but and
this is kind of what their messaging has
been they're trying to educate people
and being like for every Leonardo
DiCaprio there's like a thousand camera
operators yes or extras or a background
actor who literally lives hand to mouth
Yes these aren't people like Kevin Bacon
right and so they have people like Kevin
Bacon going on GMA trying to put that
message forward someone look Drew
Barrymore doing this like being a it
it's giving greedy it's giving greedy
it's not a good look it's giving I'm
over it right and also like I I
sometimes feel pangs of guilt for being
able to work because I've a lot of
people that work for me and with me that
are a part of the writer strike and a
part of Screen Actors that's interesting
yeah so like I like they tell me about
what's going on and it makes me feel
kind of guilty that my life hasn't
whatsoever been affected because we're
all in media
um so the fact that she's doing this
when she can hella afford to take time
off and stand in solidarity is very bad
look and it is but it's like a it's a
moral gray area not moral gray area it's
a gray area because
she's in compliance like she's not
technically crossing the picket line
technically technically but it doesn't
look like she's a sag member who
supports other sag members if you're
like not technically cheating on your
partner but your partner feels a certain
way about the way you're acting well
then technically do whatever the [__]
they say and this is just such a weird
move for Drew Barrymore who is always
but especially in recent years kind of
become like an America's sweetheart type
of absolutely so to intentionally do
something very controversial yes and the
the strike is like a very hot button
issue and people are very like
um
like emotional about it because it's you
know it's people's lives so for her to
like intentionally I know I have to
imagine financially she she's fine
of course she doesn't need season four
she could wait till the strike is over I
mean obviously if it's Financial she
should just be like honestly I have a
spending problem I'm poor [__] like I
would have more respect for that because
it I agree like she's just it's a
selfish decision and it's also like
she's not socially aware if she thinks
that this isn't gonna blow back and so
WWE there is blowback wga spoke out
against the decision stating that Drew's
show quote is a wga covered struck show
that is planning to return without its
writers The Guild has and will continue
to pick its struck shows that are in
production during the strike so wga is
striking Drew now it's very messy well
the thing too is that like so you set
precedent with things like this so if
she goes on the shows better than ever
the lesson learned is writers are not
valuable and that's a [__] terrible
thing to say oh it's so true so yeah
she's so I think we all shouldn't watch
right I mean I wasn't planning on it but
I I the way she makes me want to crawl
inside my body and die no I just and
this is something we were talking about
yesterday with me Kunis and Ashton
Kutcher to intentionally make such a
poor decision in terms of how it'll
affect your Public Image there has to be
another reason but at least with Mila
and Ashton they didn't think anybody
would know I know but like we were
saying yesterday how it you know there's
a conspiracy theory that because
Scientology is so involved in this case
yes that they were somehow blackmailed
into
writing those letters did you see the
stuff so Saint hoax posted something
yesterday like it's the it's a Tick-Tock
conspiracy theorist type of a thing but
basically one of the women who was
um who accused uh Danny of rape she was
dating him are you talking about the
phone call wait wait about that
ex-girlfriend was it a phone call or was
it a post
she no she said she was present for the
phone call it's that's what I'm talking
about the phone call we spoke about it
yesterday what do you think do you think
that like because the takeaway is not so
subtly that he was the one that actually
made me potentially murdered this girl
no okay so I saw another like I'm on
Tick Tock like this girl the talk of
shame I spoke about her yesterday okay
it's a much deeper dive so one of the
her name is Chrissy Brickley who is
Danny Masterson's ex-girlfriend got it
she had said we I was there that night
of February 11 2001 I heard the entire
phone call right A friend of hers had
spoken publicly and said that what he
knows which we assume to be from Chrissy
who heard the phone call firsthand right
was that Ashton showed up to her house
she had already been killed he looks
through the window and like or he
actually opened the door and saw her
dead body and instead of calling the
police he got back in his car called his
team his lawyers called Danny got it and
came up with a plan
for how to just make himself look best
he wasn't actually involved in The
Killing that's was like kind of I think
people's first it was definitely how it
sounded yes but a friend of hers I don't
know okay so so what she's saying is
like you did something shitty in a
moment she's not saying You're a
murderer yeah okay okay
um but so for them like them being
blackmailed by Scientology
it's like an easier way for us to digest
them writing those letters because them
writing those letters as people who are
advocates for sex crimes makes no sense
yeah and Drew Barrymore who is like a
Hollywood royalty Barrymore she's been
in Sag since she was eight yeah her kind
of Crossing it's not it's not Crossing
The Pick of line but like her making a
questionable Choice makes it's one plus
one equals sock like it makes no sense I
know
so I need someone to explain this she
also in Scientology can we just blame
Scientology for everything I mean Leah
Remini does honestly I love her if it
helps to sleep at night you know what
let's do it what keeps me up at night
Fallout between JLo JLo and Leah Remini
so is JLo in the church a Scientology
still I know ever ever No then what's
the beef I don't know I like how we
think everything Leah Remini like in her
life has to do with Scientology but it
does it does like she didn't go to their
wedding Ben Affleck like they were so
tight what would make you fall out with
a friend that hard
hmm I don't have many so let's take you
for example
what would make me like never talk to
you again yeah
and like let's not forget either like
it's so public yeah so it's an extra
layer of like they like they're so it's
so bad they can't even fake it yeah and
people would be like why isn't Taylor on
the toast anymore exactly like we don't
follow each other on Instagram I never
come on the toes we're never out
together honestly I think like if you
did something
like against one of my sisters yes like
I think that's that's pretty much it
yeah like I could forgive anyone but
um what would I have to do you would
have to [__] Taylor
well I guess I'll see you later okay
that's so you're I always forget how
like a crazy jealous wife you are
psychotic I like that must make Taylor
feel so nice yeah well she doesn't feel
that door to me she like never gets
jealous she's like such a secure person
it's so insulting like why do you love
yourself so much it's so disgusting go
to therapy
in other news we also have like a little
bit of sag news but it's more Dancing
with the Stars casting news a lot of
people have come out we know our
animatics is on it and this morning is
announced that Jamie Lynn Spears is
joining um a popularity contest that
she's clearly gonna lose uh Dancing with
the Stars season 32 Jamie Lynn Spears
she's putting on her dancing shoes she
will be competing with Alan burstin who
oh actually Caitlin Bristow was just in
the news for saying he was like one of
the meanest people she ever met on
Dancing With the Stars I found that
interesting yeah
um
but in light of the writers and Screen
Actors Guild she revealed that she'll be
donating her weekly salary to the
organization she can't afford that I
agree but also I just think this is like
a person who's so deeply trying to get
people to like her yeah and while this
is a nice sentiment like nobody cares
yeah I just feel I'm like how could she
rehabilitate her image
she can't and like why do people hate
her I was just trying to process this
very quickly through my head right now
as we're saying it because it's like so
we hate it right now because Brittany
hates her and we love Britney and we
love Brittany and then she like kind of
tried to capitalize on her sister's
trauma with the book and then calling on
call her daddy which really blew back in
her face yeah like she's so that's why
we hate her now yeah but we always have
no I was a Zoe want to win Queen oh
really so maybe it's just as simple as
that I don't know I feel like sometimes
when there's a stigma of teenage
pregnancy I wouldn't say I think it's
the stigma of having an insanely famous
sibling like Solange is I mean not Jamie
Lynn let's get this is not Jamie Lynn
but I just still feel like there's
always a part of me that's like are you
okay you it's actually a fair comparison
yes because because Solange is so
talented and had her own career yes but
nobody really
um talks about it right because it's in
the shadow of Beyonce exactly and that's
very Jamie Lynn although Ashley Simpson
Ashley Simpson and Solange I think is a
better comparison yes Jamie Lynn Jamie
Lynn like I was never because of my age
I didn't watch Zoey 101 because that
would have been creepy even like 20.
although I did like Wizards of Waverly
Place a little too much you know what I
stand behind I think so popular for a
reason you know good it was good [__] in
my mid-20s who cares
um but I just feel like she was the
epitome like she's not a nepo baby she's
a nepo sibling which we don't really
talk about enough yeah and I think that
Jamie Lynn definitely
um like we just felt like she didn't
deserve to be there and so that's why we
always hated her perhaps I also think
that this is just like a bad call for
her to go on Dancing With the Stars
because it is a popularity contest and
when they announce the cast you can
always tell who's gonna make the top
four it's usually a tick tock or like
someone with a lot of fans a mobilized
Army of you know devoted calls you know
Jamie Lynn doesn't have that if anything
she has like the opposite people will
call in devoted trolls people will call
in to vote for Ariana Maddox just
because she's not Jamie Lynn Spears
exactly so I don't think she'll have
success and you get paid per episode on
Dancing With the Stars so it's not going
to be a hefty sum donation oh that's why
she's decided to donate because she
knows it's going to be like one out of
ten dollars exactly after taxes after
commissions exactly it's gonna be ten
dollars
um I will not be watching dancing with
us I will also not be watching Dancing
with the Stars but maybe when they
announce the cast I think the full cast
is being announced tomorrow we should
have a standing dinner in protest to
Dancing with the Stars yeah I love that
for you or we should just have dinner
like whenever I love dinner that too I
loved it
um Good Luck Jamie Lynn you're gonna
you're gonna need it uh-huh oh wow I
just accidentally blew up this picture
of Jamie Lynn on my iPad sorry x that
out goodbye all right this next story is
so multi-layered and I wanted to talk
about it for a multitude of reasons one
because we'd love to see a podcast out
here making news former Coast tow host
Sophia Franklin yes we love her she's
making news with Abby Lee Miller
what in the [__] this is one of the most
crazy things like I don't even know how
to get through this story okay I'm just
gonna read it word for word these are
page six is where it's not mine Abby Lee
Miller attempts to second set the record
straight after admitting her attraction
to high school athletes
Abby Lee Miller is attempting to quote
set the record straight after receiving
backlash for admitting that she's
attracted to high school football
players in an Instagram video Monday the
dance mom star 57 that explained I quote
I do like those hot athletic muscular
types the jocks jocks I always have and
I always will however according to Abby
Miller who was wheelchair-bound
following a cancer battle these guys
quote must be able to go out to a club
gamble in Vegas and rent an ADA
Compliant handicap accessible man
which means you have to be 27 to rent a
car oh 25 okay the reality stars who
served eight months in prison there's so
many like they have to keep saying the
reality star who suffered who the rally
star who went to prison the reality star
who served eight months in prison from
2017 to 2018 for bankruptcy fraud also
feels that the aforementioned men should
have a business a bank account success
and passion in their own right why
didn't she just say a certain age so we
can all right don't move on circling
back to her controversial comment that
made headlines for all the wrong reasons
Miller said if you saw the movie All the
Right Moves starring Tom Cruise playing
a high school football star then you
know exactly what I'm talking about she
noted she will be attending her High
School class reunion in November and
hopes that the heartthrob is there but
if he's not I heard Tom Brady's
available
yikes okay so I am she's so
deeply unwell this is what she had said
in a recent episode of the Sofia with an
F podcast she stated oh that's my
downfall I like the high school football
players girl I still like them she even
doubled down on her stance adding not
one that used to be in high school one
that is no oh she wanted to really
clarify when she said that is when uh
Sophia Franklin ended their interview
stop it good girl Sophia I mean I feel
like Abby Lee Miller's kind of like
Beyond cancellation yeah like she's
uncancelable because she's so canceled
already she like verbally abused
a group of girls for like 10 years on
television all of them are now like
doing podcast writing music poetry like
about all the trauma that they've been
through and it's always from the hands
of Abby Lee Miller yes she literally
went to prison mm-hmm
I don't know if this is going to be the
thing to quote cancel she's literally
uncancelable and that's because like
nobody really like cares right but
this is a crazy thing to say so
this reminds me and it's a far departure
but I was on Instagram in my weird
algorithm and there was this video of a
high school football player and a girl
who's blonde in white jeans that's
jumping on him and her like legs wrapped
around him okay and then it's like what
kind of content are you being served I
don't know and then it cuts to like you
know where people like watch videos of
them they react yes yes so then it cuts
to this this girl being like
that's not his girlfriend that's his mom
and I went back and watched and it was
wow and I thought these crazy Karen's up
in these streets and Abby Lee yeah
Miller she is the Karen of all Karen's
no you know what I've I've landed cook
outside of um Tick Tock too where it's
like boy moms who like take it too far
who are like actually just like in love
with their sons literally but like I get
it like I'm so in love with Harry I know
I know but you can't like when you're in
your 40s and 50s and your son is like 16
you can't jump on him and wrap your legs
around okay that's like what they do on
The Bachelor that's really disgusting
that's really great I would even be
disturbed if it was like a girlfriend no
of course inappropriate on the field I
thought you were gonna say that's his
sister
I dated a guy one time ooh and him and
his sister
kissed on the lips over me like I was
thinking between them hmm in a vehicle
like legging her out yeah and they gave
it like a kiss goodbye and it was a lip
kiss I am not claiming incest at all
yeah no there's families that kiss on
the lips yeah but just like a to watch
somebody you're dating do that and B to
be in the like in in betwixt no we need
to talk about it it felt very like but
are you guys in love with each other we
need to talk about it okay because here
I actually grew up in like a kiss on the
mouth house or like I kiss my mom in the
mouth okay
see Tom Brady kisses I'm sorry I know no
Robert Kraft yeah no he's a freak what
the [__] I just showed me over there but
the thing is like my dad died
I don't know if I'd be like this grown
ass woman kissing my dad on the lips
these days I probably wouldn't but I
don't know because I never had the
opportunity to experience that firsthand
thanks a lot God
so I'm not sure but I also never had a
brother
right I do so I think like parent
kissing kids on mouth is different than
siblings kissing on mouth Am I Wrong
interesting hot take well here's the
thing is like as you are raising a child
because what was I watching selling OC
great season by the way highly
recommended I really am there's this
really hot guy he's married they have
two twin daughters and he was saying
goodbye to them he kissed both the girls
and lips totally fine but I thought to
myself at what age do you have to like
stop that so if you're a family that
doesn't stop it I guess it's just kind
of like normalized no but the simple but
the siblings siblings of a different
gender the siblings I just like if Ben
kissed his sister on the lips like I
would be like you better stop that's
disgusting yeah so they would never
no sound off in the comments do you have
a sibling of the opposite gender do you
kiss them on the lips or did you when
you were a kid and you didn't when you
got older like start off with your
experience this is something Jack and I
always talk about yeah and my opinion on
the matter is definitely colored by my
own experience of course well my little
brother is 10 years 11 years younger
than me I'm obsessed with him he's like
my baby yeah
um and so I feel like if he would have
let me right
I probably would you need two consenting
parties but he is like get the [__] away
from me no he's like you're too much
it's creepy like the way I used to talk
when I was on serious that I was in love
with him like if I could marry him like
he got support he was like it's
embarrassing I need you to cut it out
I'm honestly with him no no I am I'm
also with him as a woman who would have
jumped on her son on the football field
for sure you know we you can be recovery
no and it's kind of you can evolve maybe
that Mom of the video you were talking
about was just proud of the fact that
like she gave birth to a 17 year old and
she's you know fit enough for him to
hold her up I mean she's like you know
under different circumstances we would
be an attractive couple no like if I was
45 or whoever that woman is and my son
could pick me up meaning I'm like small
and frail like [__] I'm gonna be proud
of that I'm gonna post a video
you know they look like they could
topple no they they probably because he
was so young yeah
so but it's giving Abby Lee Miller it's
giving I'm a Karen it's giving like you
know what like we learning from this
whole Mila Ashton and of course Danny
whole debacle I just feel like
as the older party the onus is on us
yeah to not you know
talk about having crushes on high school
students no and like honestly I believe
Miller is such a deeply unwell person I
genuinely expected nothing less from her
and I'm like if this was someone else
maybe I'd be like cancel Abby Lee but
like Abby Lee's gonna do what Abby Lee's
gonna do Abby Lee gonna Abby Lee Abby
League you know wait and at this point
it's just it's nice to spectate yeah you
can't even be mad well yeah there are
some there's some level of crazy with
celebrity where like we kind of just get
to sit back eat our popcorn and enjoy
and there's not gonna be like the
accountability police calling Abby Lee
she's so far gone exactly I mean this
[__] went to prison
um wait but side note Sophia for ending
it good on her like what would you do if
you were in a deeply unwell and like
like scary
inappropriate conversation because I
feel like I I I'm working on this but
I'm like Queen of laughing things off
and I know now I've learned it you
cannot do so it depends what the person
would have said in a situation that you
shouldn't like this I probably would
have done exactly what Sophia did
because this is amazing press for her
podcast yeah
um she didn't agree sometimes I do that
too where I just like nod along when
people are saying something crazy just
so crazy don't have to respond I'm like
but that sounds like I'm agreeing with
it right so
but if they said something really really
bad I would just cut it out maybe even
scrap the episode right but I would have
done exactly what Sophia did because now
she's all over page six yeah it's great
podcast promo and Sophia's not
implicated at all whatsoever and
actually she comes out looking like a
hero totally so yeah
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by DraftKings Sportsbook football
is back in full swing and another week
of epic games and who's got you covered
on the action for every single one of
them DraftKings Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the NFL new
customers can bet five dollars on
football and get 200 instantly in bonus
bets so nobody's missing out on all the
action this season all DraftKings
customers can take advantage of two new
offers every game day this September you
know maybe your your man's is into
sports get into it too it's really fun
with draftking Sportsbook get in on the
NFL week
week two action with draftking
Sportsbook download the app now and use
code toast to sign up new customers can
bet just five dollars and take home 200
instantly in bonus bets only on the
DraftKings Sportsbook with code toast
the crown is yours gambling problem call
1-800 Gambler or visit
www.sot100 gambler.net in New York call
8778 Hope NY or text Hope NY
467-369 in Connecticut help is available
for gambling
call
888-789-7777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort 21
plus age varies by jurisdiction void in
ontc
sportsbook.draftkings.com football terms
for eligibility terms and responsible
gambling resources bonus bets expire
seven days after issuance eligibility
and deposit restrictions apply
today's episode is also brought to you
by Collective freelance work is booming
so many people are taking the leap and
starting their own businesses but how do
you maximize your earnings minimize your
taxes and make sure you're legally
compliant it's overwhelming confusing
and it takes time away from your own
billable hours and that's why you need
to talk to the experts at collective.com
Collective was built specifically for
businesses of one that are making over
60 000 in profit a year Collective
handles all your back office work so you
can focus on your passion not your
paperwork and stick around because we're
going to tell you about how they can
backdate your S Corp and save you
thousands on taxes this year so
Collective is the all-in-one Financial
solution for the businesses of one they
handle your business business formation
and compliance paperwork taxes
bookkeeping accounting even payroll plus
if you're already an LLC Collective can
retroactively elect your S Corp tax
status back to July 1 which could save
you thousands on your 2023 taxes in fact
Collective members save an average of
ten thousand dollars per year on taxes
with this structure a collective
membership pays for itself within just a
few months and it's a hundred percent
tax deductible you know if you're a
business person you really really can't
let that paperwork it's so boring but
it's so important you really got to be
on top of it and Collective is a great
option for you check out collective.com
toast before October 31st to potentially
save thousands of dollars on your 2023
taxes to sweeten the deal we'll also
throw in an extra 100 off when you use
our link but you have to do it before
October 31st so that's collective.com
toast you can get started with your
personal team of self-employed tax
experts collective.com focus on your
passion not your paperwork are you ready
for our next story I am so earlier I
think last week bombshell news Lindsay
and Carl
girl I feel so conflicted because I
really can't stand them okay and I think
that they're fakeity fake fake and so I
was like so it's kind of like this like
okay thank you like this was a bunch of
[__]
um but I also can't help but feel bad
for Lindsay I like actually believed in
their love
uh I thought it was like a really
healthy adult relationship I did not I
did not I did never I didn't understand
what was going on but I knew it was a
bunch of [__] well as of yesterday
Lizzy Hubbard has scrubbed Carl um all
the wedding pictures all pictures of him
from her Instagram after their shocking
breakup yep fans noticed on Monday that
almost every snap featuring the former
couple together had been deleted from
the publicist account including those
from her engagement and her bridal
shower which was just last month she did
keep recent photos uh with Carl from her
37th birthday celebration which is
captioned thank you all for the birthday
wishes I feel so blessed and loved
especially by babe at Carl Radke I feel
like she probably just forgot to delete
that one or she really liked the way
that she looked yeah but she probably
forgot she was like she's in the depths
of Despair yeah so I mean I remember all
those pictures were up for so long and
people were like they're still up it's
like yeah she's not on her phone at all
right
um I mean I scrubbed was Bend like you
did very long after we were together
um very long after yeah like I maybe I
screwed like like wedding stuff I look
so [__] skinny and pretty
um but I scrubbed that but then I kept
like a few randomly and I it's vanity
you want to keep the ones that you look
good in of course or like a special
moment but eventually you just have to
like it's either all or nothing I agree
I've never like experienced sex I've
only had one boyfriend yeah but I
imagine I would have been proud of the
fact that I had multiple partners in the
word of Vicki gumbelson so I would have
left up like yeah I used to have a
boyfriend then I had another one like I
would feel like boyfriends are like a
badge of honor like to get one is hard
so I'm looking that [__] up like yeah
yeah I'm I'm very attracted I'm really
regretting everything I've done I'm
attractive person and you especially you
you could show look people of all
genders find me hot yeah oh man I had a
boyfriend in college whoa sexy yeah Tay
hates when I talk about him have I ever
seen no one tells him no I'll show you
pictures like I've never even heard you
talk like an eight pack
an Adonis couldn't believe he even liked
me see that's the thing it's like having
a boyfriend is half like of course love
but it's half like confidence that
somebody wants to spend time with you
and things like you're hot and make out
yeah yeah he was a goodie and I would
leave that on my social media like it's
a it's like a hall of fame maybe I
should go find pictures like you know we
all have those boxes I have like my ex
files and um I should just go take
pictures and put them on my Instagram
100 they would love that yeah I mean you
said she's not jealous yeah let's test
the limits okay so Carl and Lindsay like
I I just feel like I'm having an
opposite reaction to everyone like I'm
actually upset about this you're really
upset well here's the thing I have to
come because I took their side last
season and I just like look stupid oh
well yes that would yeah no I'm telling
you you were wrong to take their side
their side is always the wrong side but
now it's really confusing because I'm
like they're both wrong whose side do I
take in this I think she forced him into
having this like really phony
performative relationship and he was
just got sick of it wow and because they
said in the reunion but I just did
exactly what I said I do you're saying
something and I'm like that you disagree
with
but like I was just like would you like
to end the podcast and go to page six
yeah literally to the checkers storms
off the set of the toast
and then honestly I could use that press
I know let's do it get out get the I
can't oh really the fact that you said
that about Theo earlier it still
bothering me get out get the [__] off my
show
take your lesbian ass out of here
homophone
I just um I feel like so they got into a
huge fight they were in the middle of
filming filming did not catch it he
literally left Montauk they were at Surf
Lodge and they got in such a big fight
in front of Danielle that he literally
got in a cab and drove back to New York
City guys that's a major fight it's like
a 400 Uber that's a crazy fight it's a
four dollar Uber X yeah it's it's insane
so like they clearly weren't as perfect
as they were purporting to be but I
don't clown on anyone for like keeping
their relationship issues private no but
when you're on a reality show it's a job
I know okay fine fine people like air
out so much it's like you're married
like keep it in the in the house too shy
too shy that's what I think but I will
say that I think it feels Savage to
cancel a wedding three months before but
also I tried to cancel or postpone my
wedding you did yeah and uh my wedding
planner was like either cancel it or do
it the postponing is stupid I was trying
to like [__] foot get more time and I
didn't have the balls yeah to cancel it
because we were so far on so I was like
well let's get married if it doesn't
work out we'll get a divorce and that's
exactly what happened and that's exactly
what happened but I do feel as if like I
have to have respect for Carl for being
like you know what
I really don't think it's a good idea to
go through like I feel like canceling a
wedding's so hard it sounds cruel but I
actually think like cruel to be kind no
I agree it's better than to to go into a
marriage knowing you're not happy right
but it's canceling a wedding is like so
crazy no it's it's especially a
destination wedding especially when it's
gonna be televised oh yeah especially
when you're like a famous person too
that's like next level I mean I think
this bought them you know this bought
summer house a couple good Seasons yeah
do you think that he did it though
because like he was so mad at her and
wanted to embarrass her or do you think
he did because it like in his court was
so just like wrong and he's on this path
of like self Revelation and I don't know
you know yeah like doing it on camera is
like mean but it also is furthering
Lindsay's career
and he's actually putting her in a
really good spot like he's giving her
the Ariana at it right she's kind of the
victim I had a conspiracy theory where I
thought that like they were deciding to
break up and then she was like throw me
a solid everyone hates me let's do this
together you can get away with murder
honestly I wouldn't be surprised if that
was the case but we have to see like we
really don't know I know I do feel
really bad I do too especially because
she was just like really in love and
really happy and so wants to get married
I know
it is sad no it really makes me feel
uncomfortable how I feel like empathy
for her and you've never liked it I do
not like this feeling that's so funny I
I I don't mind her I've just known I'm
also not like a devoted Summer House Fan
I've just known enough people who have
known her IRL who have told stories and
I've also met her a lot in person and I
it's hot and cold it's you know she's
very like really really up in your face
and friendly or she's just like really
randomly scary and it's just it's I
can't imagine having to live with
someone like that it's like an emotional
interesting roller coaster I met her
yeah I'm sure I'm sure she would kiss
your butt which you love which is the
number one way to my heart
I just literally spread my cheeks spread
them go kiss so go right to the whole
world our fifth and final story is
something that I wouldn't normally
choose
um but I think it's funny okay it's
sports related okay and I feel like you
might know about it because your wife
like football season just begun and
there's so much drama we'll see try me
my my eyes glaze over okay so it has to
do with Aaron Rodgers did you ever
happened to him last night no okay so
Aaron Rodgers is like this for anyone
who like doesn't know football he's like
kind of a major player major honestly
like was one of the best quarterbacks in
the league he's getting a little old but
he's still like pretty major right and
as of this year he's playing for the
Jets which is like the craziest thing
right the Jets are like the loseriest
team in the NFL I hate the draft they
can't get arrested my God like they're
so bad always and forever like to be a
Jets fan is like a lifelong
illness punishment yes
but this kind of prolific quarterback is
joining our team so for the first time
ever like there is hope there is
excitement there is Buzz around the Jets
first game last night
Aaron Rodger is likely done for the
season with the Achilles injury that's
not good no
so the Jets quarterback will undergo an
MRI exam tomorrow or today
according to head coach Robert sella
after the Jets 22 at least they won it
is believed that the four-time MVP is
suffering from an Achilles injury MRI is
probably going to confirm what we think
is already going to happen so prayer is
tonight but it's not good I heard for
Aaron this is all the coach saying I
hurt for Aaron and how much he has
invested in all of this I'm still going
to say a prayer and still going to hold
out hope he got tackled he got I think
that's what they call a sack he got
sacked and he had to be escorted off the
field in like a little golf cart oh my
God you think shailing Woodley texted
him that's a good question we're one of
my favorite couples I do I do too she's
like a deeply kind of like uh granola
yes yeah woo-woo forever yeah like we
shared Souls yeah we shared sold put
some Sage on it yeah I'll send you my my
psychics number I feel bad for him I
feel like though I've been trained to
not like Aaron Rodgers I don't really
know why my wife she's in control of all
my football feelings so like we just we
hate him she hates him so I hate him I
don't really don't know why I'm not
invested enough in football so I respect
fact that he's a good player and I also
respect that he date celebrities like I
loved his involvement in the bachelor
you know his brother won The Bachelor
yeah but they don't they don't like each
other they don't talk then there were
the Olivia munirs oh and I love her then
they were the Danica Patrick years I
forgot about that then there were the
Shailene Woodley years and now there are
the nobody I think that nobody hears I
just hate the Jets I personally
um
my hop boyfriend took me
and it was the first time in my life I
ever called the c word and fellow like
fan uh some guy was like sit down sit
down sit down and everybody in front of
us was standing so I was like sir we
have to stand like it's just it's a
chain reaction yeah and he uh was like
shut up and sit down you I'm not even
saying it see you in yeah you know and
it just like it really hit like a gump
putt gut I know if I've ever been called
I am telling you you would know because
when you get called a c word by like
kind of a stranger or like out in public
it's very like
it's such a crazy sharp word it's very
so um I think I've been called the c
word in like a fight with my sisters
like which one called you that I don't
want to say
but it was like a bad fight I can't even
honestly I can't picture any of the
girls saying it I've recently been
saying that word I kind of love it I
want to take it take my power back oh I
love it if you put a y on it it's
fantastic of course Very Erica Jane of
you I also I have a co-host that says uh
contosaurus and I love that it feels it
doesn't even feel like you're saying it
you know but you are
um but you are so I went up and I
screamed at him and I said like you have
a daughter
and he's like yeah I do and I was like
get trash your team is trash get trash
your daughter's trash everyone's trash I
literally sound like a Boston native
you're trash and I tattled to like I
kind of do it's coming out did it come
out yeah do it again uh trashy trash I
mean Boston you can really hear like
with the A's and R's we like flipping
like we were going past a thing called a
Barber Spa I don't know and my dad went
look a Bob's Bar I said that is the most
[__] Boston thing I've ever heard but
people think my dad is Australian
that's how thick his accent is Boston
does have yep an Australian resemblance
yes
oh no
don't judge my Coke Zero
you're such a [__] [__] you sound
like Jimmy no you sound like what's her
name Fat Amy from um Rebel Wilson oh no
hi guy
I love Australian accent like I wish I
could really do it oh Taylor Donahue
she'll never leave me for an Australian
it's guaranteed why is she finds it when
I watch below deck Australia she's like
her ears are bleeding I haven't watched
kept up with below deck but I've been
hearing there's like a big drama with
fabulous with like production to get
involved there was a girl who drank too
much it was a really Aisha what's her
name Aisha Aisha oh sure Australian
accent is turned and she was like the
hero right her and that other guy yeah
they saved the girl they saved the girl
production actually saved the girl good
for them and the showrunner is Darren
carp you know Darren yes Darren carb's
girlfriend is a showrunner I didn't know
that yes and so she really was the hero
of the heroine I know that was a crazy
situation they really stepped in it was
it was it was the way to handle a
situation like that that was during
toast break and I was just like down a
rabbit hole watching so many Clips I'm
like who is this guy and then that girl
who was like apologizing for him and
then she got hired too good she was
Laura she was the worst the worst the
worst yeah well you know I could talk to
you forever I love you I love you thank
you so much for being here again two
weeks in a row we so appreciate it you
know honor and a privilege and if you
guys liked what you heard here today I
feel like I kind of took a back seat and
let you just kind of tell your stories
and I liked it well thank you so much so
you liked what you heard here today
she's got so many more stories and she's
not afraid to repeat them head over
Taylor hosts a free podcast it's called
Taste of Taylor you can find it anywhere
you get your podcast it comes out every
week but she also does a daily show it's
on patreon it's 6.95 for a Daily Show
it's a great price it's patreon.com the
Taylor Striker show did I forget
anything no follow her on Instagram at
taylorstracker yes follow her on Tick
Tock at Taylor's trucker good luck over
there thank you so much for listening to
the testimony Morning Show where we do
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so you're watching us on YouTube
please don't subscribing give this video
thumbs up also available podcast
box all the places
we are hope you have an amazing day we
are in studio tomorrow with Hannah
burner that'll be a fabulous episode
love ya bye